la première star de ce qu'on pourrait
appeler le tiers-monde musicale est
décédé hier des suites d'un cancer c'est
lui qui a contribué à sortir le reggae
musique d'origine jamaïcaine des ghettos
de kingston il était le porte parole des
imprimés du tiers-monde
il avait réussi à atteindre des millions
de personnes avec cette musique issue du
calypso et du blues le reggae en europe
avec le mot le mouvement punk que le
reggae a redonné un second souffle
ce qu'on appelait le mouvement du
rock'n'roll qui avait tendance à se
scléroser bob marley était né à kingston
en 45 et il est mort d'un cancer
généralisé patrice drevet
fils d'un officier britannique et d'une
petite fille d'esclave né à kingston
jamaïque petite île des caraïbes au sud
de kouba bob marley a véhiculé sur toute
la planète
l'idéologie rasta des rastas une dizaine
de milliers de jamaïquains dont le dieu
est hailé sélassié le négus ancien
empereur d'ethiopie mais surtout il a
exporté le reggae est une musique qui
l'a transformée en champs d'amour et de
révolte dans lequel il dénonce les
oppressions et la misère ces images sont
celles de la tournée française en juin
dernier
tourné au cours de laquelle l'équipe de
tf1 la rencontre et cela s'est terminé
le 3 juillet devant 50000 spectateurs au
bourget près de paris
c'est la vérité c'est que dieu donne la
vie à l'homme on est dieu aussi qu'il
doit vivre as phase ne s'est pas de
salle tandis que la politique tu les
hommes les divisent deux complices
doivent elles ne sont plus ensemble
là c'est ce qui arrive c'est que les
gens s'entretuent
je vous parle pour des idées politiques
parlent 6 1 je pense que sans la
politique les gens vivraient plus libre
la couleur de la peau de l'homme n'a pas
plus d'importance que la couleur de ses
yeux
vous savez je ne pense pas que la
couleur soit une chose primordiale
ce qui est important c'est ce que
l'homme a dans la tête ça c'est la
réalité leur sang au delà de sa lutte
pour les rasta jamaïcain s'est en fait
pour tous les laissés pour compte du
tiers-monde que bob marley se battait
depuis 20 ans
ap
hu
coc
non
wyatt
cardillo
aiea
bob marley qui est mort à l'âge de 36
ans d'un cancer généralisé à dessein
exceptionnel et un grand serviteur de la
musique d'aujourd'hui qui avait fait
souvent des des triomphes et en
particulier chez nous